Let's suppose that x and y are numerical.
Do x and y have anything to do with each other?
Let's try to pose the question in a more precise way.
You've been collecting records and
so, you can form a joint probability table between x and y.
So we can say in an absolute sense, in a prior probability sense.
What degree of certainty do we have about x?
If x takes on the values x1 or x2 we can ask,
what's the probability with which it takes on those values?
So, from the table here we know we can just evaluate those numbers.
They're just 0.29 and 0.71.
Now let's suppose that we know y is stuck at y1.
Does this make us more certain at all about what x is?
Specifically what's the conditional probability that x is x1 or
x2, given that we know y is fixed at y1.
Well again we can just directly evaluate it from the table.
It's 0.16 and 0.84.
So it seems that knowing that y is stuck at y1 has told us
something about the value of x, right?
Intuitively we know that.
It caused the probability to skew a little bit to one side.
In this case, towards x2.
It turns out there's an expression to measure the degree of
skew of a probability distribution.
This expression is called entropy.
Specifically, let's suppose that a random variable x takes on the values x1,
x2 though xk.
The entropy for the probability distribution of x is labeled h of x.
And it is defined as minus p1 times log of p1 minus p2 times log of p2 and
so on through pk.
Otherwise written as minus 1 times the sum of pi log pi.
Now the base of the logarithm isn't necessarily important.
If the base is base two, then, the units of entropy is called bits.
If the base is e, then the units are called nets.
Traditionally in computer science, we use base two,
but, it's not really super important.
Now to see what's behind the expression h of x.
And why this formula was chosen over other options for formulas and much more
details about information theory in general, see the instructor's notes.